[Musique]
très bien je peux l'affirmer mais on
peut nous sauver non non non non restait
la verte elle est très belle cette
langue
bonjour albert muteba bonjour vous êtes
chercheur en neuroscience cognitive et
en même temps vous êtes psychologue
clinicien alors on se pose cette
question est ce qui se passe des choses
nouvelles dans notre cerveau pendant le
confinement
en fait pour répondre à cette question
il faut qu'on se base sur ce qu'on sait
déjà parce que c'est très difficile de
faire des études en ce moment en tout
cas sur le cerveau on peut sur la
psychologie avec des questionnaires
c'est un peu plus simple et en général
les différentes informations que nous
avons viennent de plusieurs
environnements certains environnements
plus comparable que d'autres par exemple
l'environnement carcéral où c'est très
compliqué de faire des de tirer des
conclusions parce que il ya une
contrainte et à l'environnement auquel
on pense pas souvent c'est les
astronautes qui sont confinés sur la
station spatiale qui ont des skype des
zooms comme voilà en train de faire qui
regarde des séries sur netflix qui
appellent leurs familles la différence
c'est qu'ils sont entraînés on a aussi
les personnes les routiers on pense pas
aux routiers qui vivent dans leur camion
des fois trois quatre cinq six mois de
l'année sur la route et dorment à
l'arrière de la banquette est aussi font
des appels vidéo et hydra et on a des
personnes qui travaillent sur les plate
forme pétrolière en haute mer qui sont
aussi confiné et en général n'observe
pas vraiment de changement parce que
nous sommes une espèce qui qui qui est
assez brillante en san suu kyi peut
assez bien supporter les difficultés et
même si plus récemment on a installé une
sorte de récit qu'on est des êtres
fragiles sommes traumatisés par
n'importe quel changement
en général au niveau du cerveau ça veut
pas dire que c'est pas difficile ça veut
pas dire que y'a pas des personnes qui
sont en souffrance psychique en
souffrance de l'éloignement social dans
des situations précaires qui ne
dépendent pas de l'individu on n'est pas
tous égaux face au confinement j'entends
souvent légende et on est à gauche fasse
confinement pas du tout les divisions
sociales la précarité maximise les
effets délétères qui existait déjà mais
je pense pas qu'on puisse attribuer
uniquement ses effets au fait de rester
dedans par contre où ça risque d'avoir
un impact cod confinement quand on va
retrouver un espace familier avec des
habitudes très différentes on va devoir
vivre avec le virus peut être même
plusieurs mois voire même une année ou
plus qu'est-ce que ça va changer à votre
avis même dans dans la relation sociale
peut-être même dans nos comportements
cognitifs est ce que cette distanciation
sociale cette suspicion sur les sur les
poignées de porte sur les boutons
d'ascenseur qu'est ce que ça va avoir
comme conséquence je pense que c'est là
où on voit voir plus de différence
beaucoup plus que pour le confinement
parce qu'encore une fois nous sommes
nous avons un peu des êtres d'habitude
et et moi je suis chez moi j'ai la
chance d'être chez moi mes habitudes ne
changent pas beaucoup parce que c'est à
l'espace familier qui dépend de moi et
donc je refais ce que j'ai l'habitude je
cuisine comme je cuisine d'habitude
ne leur dis comme je suis
demandeur d habitude je lis les livres
que j'ai chez moi par contre quand on va
d confiné on va retrouver un espace
habituel donc nous l'espace public mais
avec des comportements complètement
inhabituelle on va pas pouvoir
directement repartir au bar au café dans
le métro il pense à condamner certains
sièges avoir des marquages au sol etc
c'est quand nos habitudes sont vraiment
bouleversée qui a des changements qui
peuvent se passer autour de notre
appareil fichés et c'est ça qui va être
très intéressant pour voir comment
est-ce qu'on va réagir est-ce qu'il va y
avoir de nouveaux produits qui émergent
pour pouvoir par exemple j'ai vu une pub
sur facebook c'est pour ça que j'y pense
comment ouvrir les poignées des portes
sans les toucher avec une sorte de clé
comment est-ce qu'on va refaire pour le
travail le premier ministe par exemple
proposer des horaires décalés certaines
personnes qui commencent à différentes
heures pour étaler et donc c'est ces
changements-là qui risque d'avoir plus
d'impact que ce qu'on est en train de
vivre maintenant mais quand notre façon
de vivre est altérée de façon assez
durable aussi c'est pas éternel
ça s'inscrit ces nouveaux gestes d'un
point de vue cognitif sas intériorise
cette distanciation sociale c'est
vraiment dans la durée ça dépend combien
de temps ça dure et combien est-ce qu'on
se décale par rapport à notre habitude
je vous donne un exemple très très
basique les téléphones portables pour
tous les deux on a frôlé invaincus dans
ce monde sans téléphone portable
et on a mis un peu de temps pour
s'adapter mais maintenant c'est devenu
quelque chose qui existe partout les les
appels vidéo à distance ce quelque chose
que nos technologies de la bande
passante ne nous permettaient pas de
faire aussi bien que maintenant mais on
s'habitue la différence avec le dôme de
confinement c'est qu'est ce qu'on va
s'habituer à quelque chose qu'on va
devenir rechange et après parce que le
but c'est que ça ne viennent pas notre
quotidien ou est-ce que ça va être
quelque chose qui est dans la durée je
pense que la question clé c'est combien
de temps est-ce que ça dure si ça dure
très longtemps évidemment qu'on va
intégrer de nouvelles habitudes que
j'espère on va devoir re désapprendre
une fois qu'on aura un vaccin ou une
solution pour le virus et sinon
effectivement on va devoir créer de
nouvelles dynamiques sociales comme ça a
déjà été le cas à la différence que
maintenant on le fait par contrainte à
cause du virus on a déjà de nouvelles
dynamiques sociales pour des raisons par
exemple les avancées technologiques
comme je disais les appareils portables
ou les voitures ou les avions dans cette
période dont on ne connaît pas la durée
ni pendant ni après est ce qu'on peut
supporter de ne pas savoir si on est
vecteur ou si on a pas de virus si on va
être testée pas testé est ce qu'on peut
supporter de ne pas savoir quand est-ce
qu'on aura le vaccin est ce que
l'incertitude c'est quelque chose avec
lequel on peut vivre au quotidien alors
justement moi une grande partie de mon
travail c'est sur l'incertitude sur
comment est-ce que notre cerveau réagit
face à l'incertitude et il ya plusieurs
facteurs là aussi qui sont en jeu la
première que je veux prendre cette
opportunité pour bourg exprimer une idée
qui peut-être une patrie commune c'est
que on a souvent aux rondes j'entends
souvent dire que les gens ont besoin
d'être rassurés quand qu'on n'aime pas
l'incertitude alors que dans la
littérature scientifique ce qu'on voit
c'est que et c'est très important de
transmettre l'incertitude quand il ya
une situation très importants de parts
infantiliser il ya beaucoup d'articles
qui montre que en tant que scientifique
ou les responsables politiques ou etc
c'est très important de taj et
d'incertitudes avec des personnes quand
on dirait une personne connaît dans une
situation incertaine c'est surement pas
des agréable mais c'est mieux que de
prétendre une fausse certitude qui après
va donner des signaux mixtes comme on a
vu par exemple sur ce soit sur les
masques on a besoin des masses ou pas
que ça soit sur
les élections il faut confiné mais faire
les élections ces injonctions
paradoxales sont très compliquées donc
il ya l'incertitude vis-à-vis du futur
qui est quelque chose qui doit être
communiqué c'est très important d'être
vraiment très clair sur ce point de dire
on ne sait pas et c'est pas vrai que les
gens ne peuvent pas supporter ça ça
c'est un premier pan le deuxième pan
c'est l'incertitude qui est lié à moi
donc est-ce que je suis malade est-ce
que je vais contamine quelqu'un et c'est
vrai et là on se retrouve vraiment dans
les troubles anxieux
ou dans ce cas là c'est une anxiété qui
est légitime c'est à dire c'est une peur
qui est légitime qu'il faut
déculpabiliser
c'est pas une bonne façon de de faire de
vouloir tout le temps allait bien si
j'ai peur parce que je vis avec
quelqu'un qui est par exemple à g et
j'ai peur de le contaminer cette peur va
me permettre de faire les gestes
barrières pour ne pas la contaminer ça
une fonction les personnes les plus
stressés qu'ils ont peur de cette
incertitude d'avoir le bac ça ou pas
sont celles qui se confie le mieux le
mieux par exemple si moi je suis pas du
tout stressé par le par le virus je sors
sans masque je fais la bise à tout le
monde et c'est là que ça devient
dangereux donc ça va même une fonction
d'utilité cette peur tant qu'elle ne
devient pas excessive ou paralysante
qu'est ce qui vous dit vos patients est
ce qu'il ya la peur de l'extérieur au
moment de sortir la peur de reprendre le
travail votre métier vous avez
l'impression qu'il a changé dans la
période alors bien sûr il bien sûr que
mon métier on voit ça depuis moi je
travaille plus que d'habitude presque
depuis le début de l'épidémie mais l'epr
sont souvent centrés sur les autres
est-ce que je vais donner la maladie à
quelqu'un est ce que je suis en porter
sans le savoir surtout pour les proches
qui ont des personnes âgées ou à risque
dans leur entourage plus que sur soi il
ya évidemment les personnes qui sont
très anxieuse qui s'inquiète pour elle
même et évidemment il ya une sorte
d'incompréhension
selon les considérations des uns et des
autres et beaucoup de personnes me
disent est ce que je vais aller risquer
ma vie pour aller au boulot à la caisse
de mon supermarché pour un salaire qui
est vraiment pas très élevé et ça c'est
des caisses tellement qu'ils vont
probablement être plus large mais aussi
surtout de voir ressortir en sachant que
le virus est dehors à un coût cognitifs
qui est important c'est à dire j'ai
accepté quelque chose pas moi je albert
j'ai une personne accepter quelque chose
que je n'accepterai jamais qui est de
rester chez moi pendant deux mois et là
soudainement on me dit tu peux sortir
mais la raison pour laquelle je suis
resté chez moi et encore là le virus est
encore d'or et donc on appelle ça de la
dissonance cognitive comment est ce que
je vais résoudre ce conflit de vouloir
des sans prendre le métro alors que ça
fait deux mois que je suis chez moi cap
est bloqué précision logiquement oui oui
je pense que beaucoup de personnes vont
avoir beaucoup beaucoup de mal à
reprendre l'activité ça veut pas dire
que tout le monde va avoir 7 doute cette
difficulté et comment est-ce qu'on gère
cette dissonance d'un en rationalisant
on peut rationaliser en mettant des
masques on va en avoir les y en un gel
hydroalcoolique je pense qu'il ya
certaines personnes qui vont peut-être
nous aider voitures qui vont pas vouloir
prendre les transports en commun
certaines personnes vont vouloir
insister pour rester en télétravail et
selon les tempéraments des uns et des
autres on va tous devoir trouver des
manières de rationaliser il ya encore
des gens qui disent ce n'est qu'une
forte grippe mais qu on en fait tout un
plat tout ça c'est des mécanismes de
rationalisation de la dissonance
cognitive la banalisation et la
dramatisation les comportements de
sécurité etc en même temps dans ce monde
d'interrogation d'incertitude ya
énormément de fake news énormément de
théories du complot et ce qui frappe
c'est que le niveau d'adhésion à toutes
ces fausses nouvelles et très élevé
comment vous l'expliquez ça en fait plus
quelque chose est incertain et plus sont
bons on a de la place pour l'interpréter
chacun comme on veut c'est beaucoup plus
facile d'interpréter quelque chose qu'on
ne sait pas que par exemple je vous dis
je sais pas deux fois de égale 4 vous
pouvez pas l'interpréter n'y a pas
d'ambiguïté là dedans y'a pas
d'incertitude c'est quelque chose c'est
pour ça qu'on utilise des formules en
mac pour que pour que personne ne puisse
les interpréter alors qu'on peut faire
un commentaire de texte et chacun voir
ce qu'il a envie de voir quand on était
au collège et au lycée et qu'on est en
train de vivre
on est en train de vivre une période où
c'est plus simple de mettre notre propre
vérité attention il faut pas tomber dans
le relativisme ça veut pas dire que tout
se vaut mais sur un curseur mais petit à
petit ce chan va se réduire au fur et à
mesure que notre connaissance de vienne
que nos connaissances deviennent de plus
en plus
solide ces choses vont se réduire mais
après il faut juste aussi alerté au fait
entre les personnes qui adhèrent à des
théories du complot et est ce que ces
personnes vont agir dessus beaucoup de
personnes par exemple qui adhèrent à la
médecine alternative en temps normal
qu'ils disent moi je me souviens juste à
l'homéopathie ou aux médecines douces et
aujourd'hui si elles ont le covidien en
difficulté à respirer elles vont aller à
l'hôpital elles vont pas rester chez
elle donc il faut séparer l'adhésion des
comportements parce que souvent on pense
que si quelqu'un a des roues
automatiquement il va agir selon la
pensée et c'est pas vrai on regarde on
voit beaucoup beaucoup de personnes qui
adhèrent à plein plein de théories du
complot quand ça les touche à eux ils
reviennent à un comportement plus moyen
entre guillemets il ya évidemment des
personnes à qui ça fait beaucoup de mal
et c'est quelque chose qui peut lui un
peu des fois les débats par exemple pour
moi l'impact des théories du complot le
plus grave c'est pas juste sur la santé
sur l'art est versée sur les relations
interpersonnelles il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de deux personnes qui par
exemple que je suis en thérapie qui ont
aidé que des problèmes de couple ou des
problèmes avec leurs familles autour de
l'hydroxyte l'euro qu'il de le
laboratoire p4 de one est ce que c'est
la france qui l'a reconstruit est ce que
le virus vient du gouvernement chinois
est ce que l'on sait les américains
qu'ils ont implanté en chine parce
qu'ils ont des sentiments l'un d'eux
chinois et ça crée beaucoup plus de
conflits sociaux que de co2 de
problématiques de comportement ou je
vais pas me soigner parce que j'ai
décidé de que ça n'existe pas de
coronavirus quand vous entendez rien ne
sera plus comme avant oui quand vous
entendez qu'il faudra tirer des leçons
ces grandes phrases définitives
est ce que le fait de penser ou de dire
que les choses vont changer car monde
meilleur est possible
après ça peut permettre d'aider à des
personnes de tenir dans la période alors
ça peut permettre d'aider mais ça peut
aussi
freiner parce que on pense et c'est
ainsi une idée vraiment de community
fonds pense que quelque chose parce que
j'ai dit que ça va se faire ça me permet
de ne pas quelque part le faire c'est
c'est un parallèle très proche pour
expliquer un peu cette idée n est pas
hyper certes c'est un peu comme les éco
gestes avec le réchauffement climatique
c'est à dire on a remarqué je travaille
sur le changement climatique avec 1 un
labo que j'ai co fondé
sur l'idée comment par exemple pas
prendre de sacs en plastique au
supermarché éteindre les lumières etc
c'est en train d'avoir une sorte d'effet
de déresponsabilisation de me dit je
fais des trucs pour le climat est
derrière donc je prends par exemple
l'avion pour aller voir mon meilleur ami
au pérou mais ça c'est pire que tous les
petits éco gestes que je fais au
quotidien et donc le risque c'est que
cette phrase se dire rien ne sera comme
avant peu me rassurer mais aussi me
déresponsabilise parce que rien ne sera
comme avant très bien mais c'est qui qui
va le faire quand je le dis c'est comme
si ça va être fait par une sorte
d'entité floues ou tout seul une sorte
de baguette magique va bim changer le
monde et donc ça peut rassurer mais en
même temps ça peut aussi être une sorte
de frein à l'action en se disant
quelqu'un déjà s'en occupe c'est pas à
moi de le faire c'est intéressant de ces
regards un peu voilà multidisciplinaire
merci beaucoup au revoir
[Musique]